We are the eternals the avengers thor spider-man
but we have thena hello i'm sure that was a lot of
fun for you it was in 10 days eternals assembled
great line experience the marvel cinematic event
centuries in the making dad i saw him on tv with
the cape shooting laser beams i don't wear a cape
listen it has begun
it is time
Welcome back everyone is charlie this will
be my new marvel eternals trailer video they
just dropped a bunch of new footage talking
about the avengers i'll explain how this
sort of connects with the other marvel movies and
the other avengers characters in present day we're
doing a giveaway for movie tickets and disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is just be
a subscriber and post all your theories about
the movie on the video if you have had a chance
to see the movie because it has been screening a
couple places a couple days early please do not
post spoilers on this video though i've already
posted my review video for the movie so i'll add a
link for that down in the description below if you
have not watched that yet my videos for the post
credit scenes my full breakdown easter eggs videos
for the entire movie will start posting next week
after the movie does come out everywhere so be
sure to go see it when you have the chance but in
the new trailer footage kingo is talking about the
avengers about spider-man thor iron man captain
america the hulk all the most popular avengers
comparing them to the fellow eternals team members
trying to hype them up the person holding the
camera who he's talking to is his assistant karoon
like they're in the middle of a road trip doing
their big avengers assemble with the eternals team
putting the team back together it's all because
kingo is trying to make a documentary movie about
the eternals what their mission is what they've
been doing for the past 7,000 years to guide
humanity and help them evolve over time so the
present day world after avengers end game like
everybody in present day will know them as well as
they know the avengers characters there's still a
little confusion about this too like who knows
what in earth after avengers endgame do regular
people know everything that happened do they know
about thanos do they know what the avengers did
did they know about their time heist mission so if
you didn't realize the world knows who pretty much
all the avengers are like spider-man for instance
is a good example because he just got doxed by
mysterio so everyone knows that peter parker is
spider-man now but even before that the entire
planet for the most part at least anybody with a
screen or anybody that watches the news knew that
spider-man was on the avengers team and helped
save the universe during the falcon and winter
soldier episodes they also clarify with a couple
details they go to the smithsonian exhibit for
captain america and world war ii when falcon is
walking around with war machine and they're kind
of talking about the legacy of captain america
and why falcon didn't initially take up the shield
they passed by a new part of captain america's
exhibit like they've added to it after the events
of avengers end game in that part of the exhibit
explains all of captain america's history through
avengers infinity war and avengers end game
including the time heist like on the exhibit
it literally says the plan and that's basically a
reference to the time heist mission so most casual
people that just watch the news walk around or
have visited the smithsonian exhibit know that
time travel exists and also during spider-man far
from home you notice that there are a bunch of
movies on the plane when spider-man is just cueing
up what he's going to do while they're all flying
to europe there's a bunch of cheesy in-universe
movies made about the avengers characters like
there's a movie about iron man there's a movie
about the other avengers characters so within the
world of the mcu they're also making fictitious
movies about these characters based on the events
of all the avengers movies so all the avengers
are pop culture icons that's why they become
such shorthand with a lot of these new movies even
during the shangshi movie they spent a lot of time
early in the movie casually referencing thanos
the infinity gauntlet in the snap in the blip
they also kind of turned it into a joke during
the beginning of spider-man far from home with
that high school news broadcast but during the
eternals movie in present day after avengers end
game this is taking place right around the same
time that spider-man far from home is taking place
and at this point in history nobody knows who
the eternals is they've completely forgotten
about them because they've all gone to ground for
about the past 5,000 years so kingo isn't cloud
chasing or anything like that even though they
use him for a lot of comedic relief in the movie
he genuinely wants to educate the world on how
big a deal the eternals are well most of the
other eternals are 50-50 on whether or not they
want any kind of recognition because for about 90
of the movie they're still meant to be abiding by
the terms of their mission to guard this celestial
egg that's growing inside earth and stop the
deviants from messing with the celestial's plan
but one of the reasons why they've been so quiet
for the past five thousand years is because there
haven't been any big deviant attacks and they
have not been contacted by the celestials it's
the same relationship that the celestials have
with eternity talking about big cosmic concepts
so if you're not familiar with the celestials
they're created by eternity after eternity is
born during the big bang eternity is like the
living embodiment the living consciousness of
the universe itself but the whole idea is that
when eternity creates the celestials the celestial
hosts like irish and the judge jamia the analyzer
the other celestials east on the searcher even
ego the living planet is that it doesn't police
their actions it just creates them for the general
purpose of experimenting with life around the
universe in the past i made the comparison to the
god hand from the berserk manga that you sort of
left to do what they feel like doing with nobody
to police them like who watches the watchmen so
it's almost like eternity effectively abandons
the celestials like they can do no wrong like
it's not like attorneys going to show up and tell
them not to do something so they're not really
meant to be evil or good characters they just go
around experimenting with like trying to create
more celestials trying to create races and when
they feel like their experiments don't go the way
they want them to they basically white them like
that's what this scene of east on the searcher
in the guardians of the galaxy movie is all about
this is basically them wiping an experiment wiping
a planet full of life that they've deemed has not
panned out the way they wanted it to you could
also make the loki comparison from avengers ants
quarreling with the boot like the people who
are getting crushed or wiped out think that the
celestials are evil but the celestials themselves
aren't meant to be good or evil they're just this
god-tier group with crazy cosmic powers and the
universe shudders and shifts halfway across the
milky way galactus pauses the universe echoes
in a way he thought he would never feel again
and galactus remembers what it is to be afraid
and during the eternals movie the eternal's
relationship with the celestials is a lot like
the celestial's relationship with eternity in
that the celestials basically create them for
this task to help basically usher in this brand
new celestial that's growing on earth but they
don't check in with them all the time so it kind
of feels like they've been abandoned which is why
a lot of the eternals have gone to ground for the
past five thousand years there's a couple trailer
scenes that sort of show you them talking to the
celestials but it's usually only one eternal at
any given time that has the ability to communicate
with airshim the judge and the celestial host
you see him manifest above the planet just to
give you a good idea of the scale like this is
how big he is using his celestial technology to
effectively teleport himself across the universe
then communicating with ajax's character but now
that they're no longer bound by their edict to not
interfere with human affairs like that's off the
table it sets the stage for them to approach the
avengers before avengers 5 as a new team begins
to form but not every single eternals character is
going to be in avengers 5 or part of the avengers
crossovers when they cross over in other movies
before that the chiang xi post credits scene is
a good example of that spoiler warning for
the shangshi post credit scene if you have
not seen that movie yet i think most everybody's
seen it by now but during the post-credits scene
there's a couple of them discussing plot that will
affect avengers 5 as well as other future movies
but there are only a couple of the avengers there
for the meeting like the hulk captain marvel wong
is kind of like an honorary member of the avengers
there is a big question about how big the avengers
team is now the real avengers are kind of like
the core team and usually that's between six and
ten members at any given time and they'll probably
start with a smaller team again and slowly ramp up
again also i think the idea that they'll get into
with more sequels in the future is the idea about
the eternals from other planets like the eternals
from thanos's home planet titan are a good example
there are other eternals like them out there
in the universe on other planets on the similar
types of missions and for those of you asking
how this movie sort of connects with thor love
and thunder the other movies that are coming up
after this even spider-man no way home like i
said before this movie takes place around
the same time as spider-man far from home
but the present-day timeline takes place
over a single week over the seven-day period
to the emergence is going to happen so i would put
the ending of the eternals movie around the time
where spider-man is getting doxed by mysterio
and j jonah jameson in spider-man far from home
i believe thor love and thunder is also supposed
to take place right around the end of the eternals
movie around the same time spider-man no way home
is getting started the asgardians for instance
would also be affected by dr strange's spell they
would also forget about spider-man or the ones
that actually met spider-man or saw spider-man
but because christian bale is playing gore the god
butcher some of you have started to ask now too
if gore the god butcher is going around killing
gods all over the marvel universe greater gods
lesser gods anybody that calls themself a god
does that mean that gore would also come for
the eternals characters or even the celestials
my early theory is that yes eventually he
would come for the eternal's characters he
wouldn't be powerful enough to kill any of the
celestials until he created a version of the
god bomb from the comics or got like a power
upgrade on top of the necro sword like that
by itself wouldn't be enough to kill one of the
celestials but they're not going to be doing the
exact same comic book gore storyline they'll
be changing him just a little bit for the mcu
if you have any big questions about what's going
on with the eternals characters or any questions
about the cosmic mythology just write them below
in the comments my full post credit scene video
for breakdown easter eggs videos will start
posting next week after the movie comes out
and there's supposed to be a new morbius trailer
i'm sure with plenty more spider-man easter eggs
on tuesday next week if they do wind up
releasing it of course i'll do a video for it
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss that congratulations life of
nate you're the giveaway winner from my last big
marvel video please email me on my website so i
can get your details there's a link for that in
the video description below the giveaway will
also continue in all my marvel videos through the
end of the year as well in spider-man no way home
everyone click here for my brand new what if
season 2 teaser trailer video to learn about the
new episodes and click here for my new spider-man
no way home preview of the sinister 6 characters
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!